[Music]
and man in hole news submitted by hello
JK to the atmosphere a Houston man who
got stuck in a manhole nine days tells
his story that must be the most boring
story on earth I feel like that would be
you God you clearly don't know me cuz I
would have been dead and there would be
no story to tell there was a dead man
ate his foot continue I think about
being buried alive sometimes and I was
like how can I immediately kill myself
[Laughter]
you know Kill Bill like [ __ ] what did
you punch that [ __ ] [ __ ] no I can't do
that that's right you can't MacGyver
yourself out of that situation hold my
breath and die that's crazy yeah I don't
have enemies though yeah you do oh shut
the [ __ ] up
ya [ __ ] smiling Mexican what's this
story about huh this man his name is
Jason 40 years old
what he's 40 yeah and he survived let me
guess he try to be a ninja turtle and
climb down the sewer and he got stuck no
meters good he was walking punished by a
highway and there was a lot like a lot
of really tall grass and there was this
uncovered manhole that he accidentally
fell in a hole knack reason for that
reason he's suing this city that's
dangerous he ended up falling in on a
Friday afternoon he didn't get rescued
until Monday around 2:00 a.m.
cuz nobody works over the weekend days
right oh so i lapped over more than he
was eating insects and he snakes that
would fall into them when Jason fell in
he broke his ankle and his ankle just
shattered of course wasn't able to get
out or like not even stand up I couldn't
move both ankles feel like yeah yeah
and other injuries they're just saying I
[ __ ] suck you're just saying that you
couldn't stand up have you ever seen
somebody sprained both their ankles in
basketball at the same time it is
[ __ ] holy I see your ankle break but
I've only done once at a time I'm
talking about like like that's just
[ __ ] funny dude Wow
not only the person but it just looks
really goofy yes Jason out of all the
pictures to use and that is [ __ ]
Texan why that's all I picture Texas why
because that's not how Texans look he
dresses I don't know fair enough like
unless you're a [ __ ] Rancher and you
ride a horse every day pick that bucket
oh yeah I don't know looking at the
background of the tikkis I'm just saying
stuff I don't know he probably does ride
horses or some [ __ ] that just might be a
split selfie daddy took before he went
to a rodeo probably I don't really give
us a photo
everything is huge so it's about four
feet wide oh how I got stuff wouldn't
look like we was down there and he was
saying that when he was down here is
that him in there why is somebody
snapchatting him is that the fire
department construction workers were the
ones I found him so they took a photo
before they were able to get him out and
so he was saying that this whole time he
was down there the sewage water would
come up and he was there for nine days
like in sewage water every time to black
caucus every time people would flush the
toilet nearby
it's disgusting you would just have like
all the poop water and why would a male
myself me he initially had his cell
phone with him because about 10 15
minutes before he fell into the hole he
had texted his dad he was gonna be home
soon and that's when he fell and then
his phone got washed away
like immediately his fungi wash away
living nightmare it's like the movie
look and then he said that he had a
pocket knife with him and that he
thought about it many times like like
whether or not to kill themselves yes
like no I want to live and so sometimes
it would be like brown snakes I would
fall into the men Oh grab the head of
the snake slam it against the wall kill
it chop off the head and skin everything
and just eat everything inside he was
saying that the blood the snake blood
had a lot of nutrients and that like
help them stay alive that's how he did
it
I pictured a snake falling down and you
[ __ ] grab it and just bit it like a
straight-up caveman and he had a
pocketknife is that how you were doing
it yeah I mean I wouldn't know what else
to do you by the third date maybe within
the first six hours of not eating I
would have published it yeah and then
since he was that a highway the noise
pollution like just drowned out his
screams oh my and then finally that
Monday early morning he heard
construction workers that you just
started yelling and they were using a
machine to do whatever work they were
doing and then he was just saying that
he was praying to God like God please
like turn the Machine off let them hear
me please and as soon as he was pleading
the god that's when the machine turned
off and they were able to hear him so
he's he's really thankful and saying
like thanks to God I would have just
kept beatboxing until I died beatboxing
you know cuz the pipe has hella good
acoustics so you're loud just feels good
in there and it maybe even the
construction work good but always the
music coming from and then if you cut it
off then the construction workers are
but tell him to turn it back on and
don't start wandering comes close to you
so if he was beatboxing they probably
was saved in my three days I can't live
I can't even imagine what that's like
there Jase she makes me crickets she was
in so much pain he had got he had been
an accident before but this pain like
it's just course snapping both of your
good ankles snakes blood o snakes blood
after you got rescued he's got a hot
burger yeah he had a lot of you change
that this is that's crazy I had surgery
on an ankle oh my god how big was the
fall or how deep was this picture so
funny can we go back
21:23 are you gonna snap pictures
hilarious to me there's a hamburger and
that's dumb literally looks like he died
yeah like a ghost the hakama so
desaturate right here but that's the
brightest hamburger I've ever seen in my
life he was malnourished she lost a lot
of weight and I ain't trying to smile
right now a bad lighting there's too
much focus on the girl in the hamburger
where they look like it's amazing it's
like super sad does it look like she's
trying to take a selfie and he just
photobomb exactly know what this reminds
oh this reminds me of when you're in
labor and this was trying to vlog man
that's a living nightmare
ain't that the toughest dude on earth
yeah that's some [ __ ] a remanent [ __ ]
right there dude yeah I can't do that
man having toilet poop water every day
you're just drenched in it I can correct
my body can create and like that's
[ __ ] up dude just it's just literally
like you falling into a porta potty
every like 10 minutes yeah do you think
it's worse if the poop came up to like
here bottom line it did or would you
rather have it come like up to here wait
a question what's the logic you think
it's exponentially worse yes this right
here nah but this down give it to me
yeah cuz I go in my jacuzzi and
sometimes they over chlorinate that
[ __ ] and I don't like going
beneath my neck but then sometimes I
just want to wet my hair a little bit
and I try it and when I get back up just
the residue water from my face makes my
lips salty like I try to lick my [ __ ]
lips but just when I open up my mouth
some of the droplets get inside so I
guarantee you some of that poop would
water just accidentally inside if it
went past his lip well he said that he
had to do this let it go like you so you
won't drown anybody Kenny would tread
water either right it goes our [ __ ] up
ain't good incentive
especially if your hands get wet you
can't wipe your face with it just
[ __ ] like crickets and crickets are
cool high protein I mean yeah they're
cool but would you rather but check this
out though we are these chemicals and
that shit's actually bad for you and
unnatural right where's the we're
supposed to eat like crickets and snakes
and stuff we're just is nasty what if he
comes out healthy as [ __ ] because of
that that picture that you saw that
screams health he lost weight that's the
new trend
the man whole weight loss program I'm
telling you right now that you know when
you say like he just stayed he just say
snakes and crickets it just sounds like
a Cambodian night market yeah yeah but
he's saying like earlier reports they
were claiming that he was drinking the
sewage water well but he wasn't like
that's stupid I would have died so he's
like I stayed I stayed hydrated because
the water absorbed through his body
somehow like that that's what he thinks
is what I think it was a snake a snake
blood cuz that's what they say up in the
ocean if you're stranded if you ever
catch fish you should be drinking the
blood of the fish ah that's good to know
not that I plan on being there somewhere
at night so that information might be
faulty oh this guy's a survivor
nine days yeah but I bet something
happens to you like within the first day
where you kind of just accept it and you
just have you just fight to survive see
this is why I go on Amazon and I always
look at survival kits just in case
something might happen well you're the
one that's the most accident-prone I
walk around with it on you know what is
going on today huh whoa you know if
something happens right now and your
survival kit is in your house or in your
car how's that gonna help yeah good
point right this needs to be a survival
kit all right it's pretty cool they had
this thing where they had like these
like flipped starters right where
happened it's like that magnesium [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] and you can put like
pile you can file it I mean it lights on
fire immediately
we're keep on an office
then you could also just take this
little capsule right you take those
little cotton swabs and you just built
with Vaseline and you just leave it in
there and then immediate if you can
spark it like that and you can make a
fire just in case [ __ ] happen where do
it where is that right now hmm where is
it
I didn't make it yet like if I could you
know you say this right now but you just
wait till you're in a force or you're
gonna die you gotta make it happen
oh my god you wish you can't even cook
to save your life let's continue we need
to figure out turbine survival because
like the closest forest to us is like 20
miles away 250 V I've never been so
doubted in my life I'm carrying a
Vaseline cotton swabs on me all the time
now for different reasons you can't even
keep sunglasses on you dude you know
what that's so funny because I just lost
my sunglasses but for real though we've
been looking at natural disaster stuff
like and then the biggest thing is most
natural disasters you're probably gone
without food or help for like three days
ish and then the National Guard or
something might come so three days in
and the main thing is water and food
just look for stuff like that what else
is left after water and food shelter
shelter huh yeah stupid mainly water and
food you want to make sure you have that
for three days and then you can kind of
hide out hide out in your place in my
Honda Element
I have three Hershey squares in there
just in case [ __ ] happen you're prepared
how long is that gonna last you like
thirty minutes I get really hungry
I just university square and it's all
melted and you can't even eat it okay
well do you live in my car away new
stash food everywhere though I got
oatmeal like instant oatmeal things all
over chip probably but hey more protein
right
[Music]
[Music]